fireworks can actually be terrifying for  our pets some run away some end up at  shelters last year the Animal Foundation  received over 660 animals the first week  of July only about 20% of them are  ultimately returned to their families  we spoke with Kelsey Pizza from the  foundation she had some really good tips  to keep pets calm and safe on Saturday  pets do not like fireworks we know that  so the best thing to do is keep your pet  inside of your house create a safe space  so they're near maybe their kennel or  their crate or their favorite toy you  can put them inside of a closet or your  garage or a bathroom and really the best  thing you can do is try to drown out the  noise of the fireworks  Kelsey PZ adding to make sure your pet  has a collar and nametag on especially  if they are not microchipped